first they'll psychoanalyze but I'm like
none of you had Brothers
to bully you growing up none of you none
of you none of you can say anything that
my brothers have not said to me growing
up I remember like okay because my
brothers would have roasted the hell out
of me if I ever said I was a 10 oh my
gosh I I I'll hear these chicks be like
I am a 10 I'm like did you not have
brothers or like a dad like no seriously
because I remember my I remember crying
when I was like 15 or 16 because my
brother was like oh you you have I
forgot what I don't even remember he
just roasted me so bad that I started
crying and did he apologize no this man
doubled down